[Music]
sportscaster brent musburger back in the
news today last night at the end of a
college basketball game the 73 year-old
Musburger called
ESPN sideline reporter Holly Rowe smokin
hot
now a lot of people think must burgers
latest comment was just a joke but
others think once again he's being a
pervy old man now it's really not a big
deal but the important thing is it gives
me the chance to once again talk to
Brent Musburger hey Brent hey there :
alright so what exactly happened last
night you keep having this problem what
happened last night well it was just a
little joke I made about this whole
situation I apologize if I offended
anyone I hope you leave the whole thing
behind us alright well thank you very
much Brent appreciate it hey well you
have me on the phone let's check out
your studio audience Oh momma Musburger
likey is this a steakhouse cuz that lady
is sizzling all right brand that's not
helping okay who's next who's next
oh wow do I do you see what I see that
is a beautiful girl hey honey I'll bring
the guns you bring the rack okay wait
that is inappropriate alright give me
some more sugar oh good lord
hey honey want to go camping coz I'm
pitching to town hey hey don't tell the
rest but my penis just double dribble
chase I apologize
[Applause]
I said that was a bad idea I mean I'm
surprised that we actually called oh he
is hot too Wow
I'd like to double-team him in the back
court
hey you're in luck Andy I've been
looking for a new ball will paint mr.
mussburger I got all the hardwood action
you can handle right between my thighs
stop it come on buddy let's team up and
take it right to the hole listen listen
Wow Andy's enjoying it hey I don't need
a microwave to enjoy those hot pockets
shut up no improvising now once again
you're supposed to be on the phone how
can you see people in our studio just
curious
looks I'm up in the rafters going to
God's sake he's in the right way just
[Applause]
[Music]
just up here enjoying the view this must
be a poultry farm because I see lots of
hot juicy bread you know just there's
more hot ass than a donkey sauna Wow
that's stunk that listen are you talking
about fact that was faxed in shut up
what are you why you up there in the
rafters how long have you been up there
I love it up here I got some granola
bars the girls to the suc Playboy from
1982 in jars for my urine all right
that's enough thank you
[Applause]
everybody from the Emmy award-winning
ABC series Modern Family Jesse Tyler
Ferguson is on the show yeah another
redhead from the new film warm bodies
Teresa Palmer a beautiful woman oh I got
a warm body for Palmer I hardly know her
okay yeah you're getting better very
funny comedian Baron von is on the show
Baron Vaughn I want to have sex with
that guy yeah there's no joke there yeah
I know there really isn't just straight
upset all right
we're gonna take a break lot more soap